Квантова діагоналізація Крилова, або скорочено KQD, — це метод розв'язання задачі на власні значення матриці
шляхом проектування матриці на підпростір, підготовлений на квантовому комп'ютері, відповідно до методу Крилова —
потужного підходу з класичної лінійної алгебри. У цьому відео ми розберемо, що таке метод Крилова,
і як та коли його реалізовувати на квантових комп'ютерах.
То що ж таке метод Крилова? Уяви, що є матриця H, пов'язана з якоюсь науковою або бізнесовою задачею, розміром n на n.
Нас цікавить найменше власне значення e 0 та відповідний власний вектор psi 0. Визначимо
початковий вектор v, який може бути мотивований структурою H або бути цілком випадковим. Підпростір Крилова
порядку r, який позначається k r, утворюється шляхом дії H на цей
початковий вектор r мінус один разів із додаванням результату кожної подальшої дії H
до набору базисних векторів, тобто kr — це простір, натягнутий на вектори v,
Hv, H у квадраті і так далі. Загалом ці вектори не будуть ортогональними.
Класично ми часто проводимо процес ортогоналізації, дуже схожий на процедуру Грама–Шмідта. Ти починаєш
з нормування початкового вектора V і називаєш результат V 0. Потім для наступного вектора HV ти віднімаєш
його проекцію на V 0, щоб зробити два вектори ортогональними. Потім нормуєш результат. Продовжуєш так далі,
знову діючи H і роблячи результат ортогональним до всіх раніше доданих векторів, поки не отримаєш R
ортонормованих векторів, необхідних для натягу твого R-вимірного підпростору Крилова.
Маючи цей підпростір, ти проектуєш свою матрицю на нього і діагоналізуєш меншу проектовану матрицю. Є
нюанси та розширення, але це і є метод Крилова в найпростішому вигляді.
Щоб краще зрозуміти, як це працює, розгляньмо простий приклад. Якщо H — ця матриця, а V вибрано ось цим
вектором, то ми починаємо з нормування V. Щоб отримати другий вектор підпростору Крилова, діємо
один раз H на наш початковий вектор, а потім робимо результат ортогональним до V 0.
Нескладна алгебра дає ось це для V1.
Для таких малих матриць це не корисно, і зазвичай ніхто не зупиняється на вимірності Крилова рівній двом. Але якщо
проектувати H на наш новий простір Крилова K2, ми робили б це за допомогою матриці V,
у якій кожен стовпець — вектор Крилова, та її транспонованого спряженого, де вектори Крилова — в рядках. Тоді отримали б
ось цю матрицю.
Ця матриця технічно має меншу розмірність, ніж початкова. Очевидно, це скорочення тут не корисне.
Цей метод призначений для скорочення матриць з тисячами або навіть мільйонами рядків і стовпців
до кількох. То чому методи Крилова корисні? Виявляється, ця проста приписка
дії оператора часто є найефективнішим способом наблизитись до стану з найнижчим значенням або основного стану матриці
оператора. Зробімо це трохи конкретнішим, хоча повний доказ залишимо для супровідного тексту. Ми хочемо
розв'язати задачу вигляду H, що діє на вектор x, дає деяку константу, помножену на вектор x. Почнімо з
нашого здогаду власного вектора x0. Це просто наближений розв'язок. Він має похибку, яку позначимо e 0. Тепер хочемо
зробити оновлення цього здогаду, яке назвемо x1, сподіваючись покращити наше наближення. Можемо виразити це як
початковий x0 плюс якась поправка p 0, яку ще треба визначити. Можна
повторювати цей процес ітераційно, додаючи все більше поправних векторів pi.
Очевидно, хочемо, щоб похибка зменшувалась, але нас цікавить не лише стан. Ми також дбаємо про
дію H на цей стан. Тому величина, яку ми справді хочемо мінімізувати, — це H-норма цієї похибки, або норма
дії H на цю похибку.
Тепер бачимо, що це вираз, що містить p 0, і можемо запитати себе: який вибір p мінімізує
цю H-норму похибки найефективніше? З якого простору слід вибирати поправку? За певних
умов — наприклад, коли H симетрична і позитивно визначена — вибір перших r поправок з kr виявляється
оптимальним. Простіше кажучи, нам потрібен якийсь спосіб підготувати хороший підпростір, на який можна
проектувати наш гамільтоніан. І в багатьох випадках підпростір Крилова — це простір, натягнутий на вектори найефективніших
поправок до нашого початкового здогаду.
Для справжнього доказу дивись текст, що супроводжує це відео.
Все, що ми описали досі, можна зробити класично. То як і коли ми використовували б квантовий комп'ютер?
Для дуже великих матриць метод Крилова може потребувати тривалого обчислювального часу й великого обсягу пам'яті. Час,
необхідний для операції матриці H на V, масштабується як N у квадраті в найгіршому випадку.
І це робиться для кожного вектора, який ми хочемо отримати в нашому підпросторі. Розмірність підпростору R зазвичай не є значною
часткою від N і часто масштабується як логарифм від N. Тому генерація всіх векторів масштабується
як порядок N у квадраті помножений на log N.
Хоча є й інші кроки, як-от ортогоналізація, це домінуюче масштабування варто мати на увазі.
Квантові обчислення дозволяють нам змінити те, які характеристики задачі визначають масштабування часу і ресурсів,
що вимагаються. Замість залежності від розміру матриці n повсюдно ми побачимо такі речі, як кількість shots та
кількість некомутуючих членів Паулі, що складають гамільтоніан.
Давай розберемо, як це працює.
Нагадую, що оператор, який часово еволюціонує квантовий стан, — це експонента від iH поділена на h-бар. І
дуже часто, особливо в квантових обчисленнях, h-бар просто опускають у позначенні.
Один із способів зрозуміти і навіть реалізувати таку експоненційну функцію від оператора — це розглянути її розклад
у ряд. Зауваж, що ця операція, діючи на деякий початковий вектор V, дає суму членів
WEBVTT
зі зростаючими степенями H, застосованими до початкового стану. Здається, що підпростір Крилова можна просто побудувати за допомогою часової
еволюції нашого початкового стану-здогаду. І це майже так. Застереження полягає у
реалізації часової еволюції на реальному квантовому комп'ютері. Багато членів гамільтоніана не будуть комутувати між
собою. Тому хоча деякі прості експоненційні оператори, як-от e в степені мінус iz, відповідають простим
circuit-ам, загальні гамільтоніани — ні, і оскільки вони містять некомутуючі члени,
ми не можемо просто розкласти експоненту в добуток простих, як це можна зробити з числами. Отже,
це нетривіально, але це добре вивчений процес у квантових обчисленнях. Часову еволюцію
на квантових комп'ютерах ми виконуємо за допомогою процесу, що називається тротеризацією, яка сама по собі є багатою темою. Але на дуже високому рівні
розбиваючи часову еволюцію на малі кроки, скажімо M кроків, ми обмежуємо вплив некомутативності
членів. Назвімо підпростір Крилова порядку r, який ми генерували в класичному контексті, використовуючи степені H
безпосередньо, силовим підпростором Крилова kpr.
Тепер ми генеруємо подібний простір, використовуючи унітарний оператор часової еволюції u, заданий як експонента від iHt.
Назвімо це унітарним підпростором Крилова kur.
Силовий підпростір Крилова kpr, який ми використовуємо класично, не може бути безпосередньо згенерований на квантовому комп'ютері, оскільки H
не є унітарним оператором. Можна показати, що використання унітарного підпростору Крилова дає схожі гарантії збіжності,
як і силовий підпростір Крилова.
Зокрема, похибка основного стану ефективно збігається за умови, що початковий стан V має перекриття з
істинним основним станом, яке не зменшується експоненційно, і за умови достатнього розриву між власними
станами. Тут степені u стають різними часовими кроками. k-й степінь u — це крок
вперед на час k * dt.
Елемент підпростору, що часово еволюціонував на загальний час kdt, позначимо s sub k. Можна проектувати наш
гамільтоніан H на унітарний підпростір Крилова kur. Іншими словами, ми
обчислюємо кожний матричний елемент H у базисі kur. Назвімо цю
проектовану матрицю H тільда. Матричні елементи H тільда задаються ось цими значеннями очікування, які можна
оцінити за допомогою квантового комп'ютера.
Пам'ятай, що H можна записати як суму операторів Паулі на різних qubit-ах і що не всі оператори Паулі
можна вимірювати одночасно. Ми можемо сортувати члени Паулі в групи комутуючих членів і вимірювати всі
одночасно. Але може знадобитись багато таких груп, щоб охопити всі члени. Тому кількість різних комутуючих груп,
на які можна розбити члени, ngcp стає важливою. Якщо використовувати унітарний підпростір Крилова розмірності r,
результуюча матриця матиме розміри r * r. Якщо r набагато менше n, то ми
досягли корисного прогресу, і зазвичай r набагато менше 100, тобто ми можемо діагоналізувати це легко на класичному
комп'ютері. Але пам'ятай, що s n і s m загалом не будуть ортогональними. Іноді
можна діагоналізувати матрицю в неортогональному базисі. Але є числові та фізичні причини
спочатку перейти до ортогонального базису. Тому ми розв'язуємо узагальнену задачу на власні значення, використовуючи матрицю Грама s.
Елемент mn матриці Грама задається скалярним добутком s m на cn.
Як елементи H тільда, так і S обчислюються за допомогою тесту Hadamard.
Узагальнена задача на власні значення тоді набуває такого вигляду.
Як зазначено вище, розмірність унітарного підпростору Крилова R є експоненційно меншою, ніж розмірність нашої початкової
матриці N. Тому ця задача на значення легко розв'язується класично.
Підсумовуючи: починаємо з референтного стану, потім еволюціонуємо його протягом різних проміжків часу, щоб генерувати унітарний
підпростір Крилова. Проектуємо наш гамільтоніан на цей підпростір і також оцінюємо перекриття
векторів підпростору. Нарешті, класично розв'язуємо задачу на значення меншої розмірності. Порівняймо, що
визначає обчислювальні витрати при використанні техніки Крилова класично і квантово-механічно. Ми вже намітили
це для класичної версії, і немає ідеальних аналогій між класичним і квантовим підходами для всіх кроків. Але ця таблиця збирає деякі
масштабування різних кроків для розгляду. Пам'ятай, що гамільтоніани загалом мають члени, які неможливо вимірювати одночасно, оскільки вони
не комутують. Ми сортуємо члени гамільтоніана в групи комутуючих операторів Паулі, які можна вимірювати одночасно, і може знадобитись багато
таких груп, щоб врахувати всі некомутуючі члени. Щоб побудувати H тільда на квантовому комп'ютері, потрібні
окремі вимірювання для кожної групи комутуючих рядків Паулі в гамільтоніані. І кожне з них потребує багато shots. Це потрібно зробити для R
у квадраті різних матричних елементів, що відповідають R у квадраті комбінаціям різних факторів часової еволюції. Іноді
є способи скоротити це. Але в цьому грубому розгляді час, необхідний для цього, масштабується приблизно як
кількість shots помножена на кількість груп комутуючих членів Паулі помножена на r у квадраті.
Елементи s потрібно оцінювати, що масштабується як кількість shots
у кубі. Бачимо, що квантова діагоналізація Крилова може бути корисною у випадках, коли кількість комутуючих груп Паулі
в гамільтоніані відносно мала.
Ця залежність масштабування вказує на деякі застосування, де метод Крилова може бути корисним, та на інші, де він, мабуть,
не буде. Деякі гамільтоніани мають високу складність при відображенні на qubit-и, включаючи багато некомутуючих рядків Паулі,
які важко розбити на кілька комутуючих груп.
Це часто справедливо для задач квантової хімії. Наприклад, ця складність створює дві основні проблеми для
квантових комп'ютерів ближнього часу. По-перше, оцінка кожного елемента H тільда стає обчислювально дорогою через
велику кількість членів. По-друге, необхідні circuit-и тротеризації стають надто глибокими. Обидва ці пункти
будуть менш проблематичними, коли квантові комп'ютери досягнуть відмовостійкості, але їх варто враховувати в найближчому часі. Навіть системи з простішими відображеннями,
WEBVTT
ніж у квантовій хімії, можуть стикатись з тими ж перешкодами, якщо гамільтоніани мають занадто багато некомутуючих
членів. Метод Крилова найбільш корисний там, де гамільтоніан можна розбити на відносно небагато комутуючих груп Паулі
та де H легко реалізувати в circuit-ах тротеризації. Обидві ці умови виконуються. Наприклад,
для багатьох ґраткових моделей, що цікавлять фізиків, KQD особливо корисний, якщо дуже мало відомо про
основний стан. Це випливає з його вбудованих гарантій збіжності та застосовності в сценаріях, де
альтернативні методи неприйнятні через недостатнє знання основного стану.
Хоча KQD є потужним інструментом, найбільш трудомісткі аспекти протоколу — зокрема оцінка кожного
елемента проектованого гамільтоніана та перекриття станів Крилова — відкривають можливості для вдосконалення.
Альтернативний підхід передбачає наближення стану Крилова за допомогою circuit-ів тротеризації, потім вибірку
наближеного стану для отримання проекції на обчислювальний базис і потім проектування H на підпростір,
натягнутий на ці базисні стани обчислення.
У випадках, де це застосовно, ця методологія, відома як вибіркова квантова діагоналізація Крилова SKQD,
потенційно пропонує значне скорочення часу та вимог до ресурсів порівняно з традиційним KQD.
Інтеграція технік підпростору Крилова з методами вибірки в SKQD є захопливим рубежем у
квантових алгоритмах.